[Music]
Sir Elton recently postponed his Vegas
shows the weekend of the Royal Wedding
so that must mean he's gotten his
invitation right anything yet sorry yeah
we're still waiting for hours - Elton
Jane Seymour attended the charity bash
she met Harry while covering William and
Kate's wedding for et she thinks Megan
will be splendid in her new royal role
she's certainly beautiful and until she
carries herself well and and I think she
must have thought long and hard about
you know what she was going to do it
hopefully they can manage to find some
time to be happy together as well as
work allison janney is now Oscar royalty
I'd take my shoes off she was also
barefoot when she met William and Kate
last month at the Baptist
that's not exactly royal etiquette I
didn't know Kate was so tall she's my
height like yeah I mean I've granted I
didn't have my shoes on when I met her
which was another thing that I had she
you don't meet royalty without your
shoes on but they're they're pretty
relaxed and cool et has learned Megan
will soon be baptized and confirmed into
the Church of England both her mother
and father are expected at the private
ceremony at the chapel at Kensington
Palace joining harry's faith clears the
way for Megan to walk down the aisle and
on Oscar Sunday Megan's girlfriend's
treated her to a pre-wedding day spa
pampering at the 5-star Soho farmhouse
Duchess Kate did not join in the girls
party maybe she and William kicked back
shoes off and watch the Oscars
[Music]